Inter-domain routing concerns routing between
domains or autonomous systems. It involves
the reconfiguration of the border gateway
protocol, policies or configurations that are
running on individual routers in the network. Changing BGP policies at these
edge routers can cause routers inside an autonomous system to direct
traffic to or away from certain edge links. We can also change the set of egress
links for a particular destination. For example, an operator of autonomous
system one might observe. Traffic to destination
D traversing the green path. But by
adjusting B to B policies, the operator might balance load across these two edge
links, or shift all of the traffic for
that destination. To the lower path. An operator might
wish to use inter domain traffic engineering if
an edge link is congested, if a link is
upgraded, or if there's some violation of appearing
agreement. For example, AS1 and AS2 have an agreement
that they only send a certain amount of traffic
load. Over that link in a particular time window.
If the load exceeds that amount, an operator would need to
use BGP to shift traffic from one [INAUDIBLE] link to another.